what's up everyone we are sitting down
with Naveen Jane what's up Naveen ah did
awesome did loving life thanks for
coming on the show appreciate it okay so
you have so many different projects that
you're working on but you carry this
philosophy around with you it's this
moonshot philosophy so tell us a bit
about this yes the moonshot philosophy
is that there is really nothing that you
can't achieve if you can imagine it you
can achieve it and the only reason
people are afraid of doing things that
seemingly difficult is because somehow
they are afraid to fail they can't dream
big and they just afraid to fail so if
you want to move the society forward
give people a chance to dream so big
that people think they are crazy and
take away their fear of failure and
that's a society we all can sign up for
yes and I like how you made sure to say
that the most the thing that holds
people back the most is the fear of
failure and if we can get past that and
shatter through that then we can really
feel that big dream and go forth with
that risk taking in that execution
process so you also have made it clear
that this sort of like entrepreneurial
mindset around moonshots you have such a
short life only eighty years here on
this earth if you're lucky and maybe
we'll get two life extension but in that
short period of time go the biggest
possible yeah but first of all for the
first time in the human history we are
capable of achieving things that could
only be done by super powers before that
means individuals and a small group of
people can now make a dent in the
universe you don't have to be a royalty
you don't have to be a president in fact
I would argue that the nation-states and
the presidents of the country are
becoming irrelevant it is the
entrepreneur so going out and solving
the biggest problems it is not going to
be Obamacare solving the healthcare
problem or Trump care or even Putin care
is going to be an entrepreneur solving
that problem going to the moon or the
Mars or beyond it's going to be done by
an entrepreneur saying enough is enough
is the electric cars are not being built
by the government because this
somehow this you know we're gonna have a
you know cars they're gonna have no
fossil fuel it's the entrepreneurs who
go out and do those things at the end of
the day it takes one person who says
enough is enough and they can move the
nation forward and they can move the
society forwards and all of us benefit
from it so I always argue they're always
going to be the companies they're always
going to be the people who are going to
be the parent site on humanity and
humanity always comes together to kill
those parasites and that's what we are I
love how you just have this amazing view
of like entrepreneurship is actually
it's one of the most important things if
not the most important thing is to
envision what you want to live in the
future and how you want to make the
world better and then go and do it and
build a team with other people and go
change the world I love that mentality
about moonshots it's such a short life
so we gotta go and make the most out of
it in the short period of time that we
have okay cool that's a bit about
moonshots yeah yes I'll just simply
saying well that part of other moonshot
really is the mindset this mindset of
abundance rather than the mindset of
scarcity